愛国心について質問が多く来ていたので
はい。はい。
これについて校調にお話いただきたいんですけど黒心は誰でもあるやろ。ないのおるんか?
若い人からの質問だと
校長のお話がだんだん理解できるようになってきて
なるほどなと思うことは多いんだけど愛国心だけよくわからないっていうのは
うん。ええ、それ自分の心を偽ってない愛国心があるないなんていうことを考えるということは考えるな。
感じろ。考えることは理性だから間違っ
とる。感じるのは本能だから正しい。必ず
人間なら愛国心を持ってる。本能として。
だから今野球のニュース番組見てごらん。
大谷ばっかりやないか。あれアメリカで
起こっとることや。だけど大谷活躍すると
喜ぶ。これ愛国心やないか。オリンピック
の時なんかどうや金メダル何個取った?
あれ取ったわ。が残念というは騒ぐやない
か。あれ全部愛国やろ。ふざけたことに
愛国は消しからんと言っとった朝日が
オリンピックになると愛国愛国心を
盛り上げるんや。ああいうふざけた会社や
。我々は行列な愛国を持っとるんだ。それ
が悪いと言われたら困るやろ。
愛国って国を愛する心って書くと思うんですけど
国を守るだから愛の定義からしてごらん愛というのはみんな愛の定義できるかな?難しいこと言わんでもええんだ。ただ守るということ。親が子供を必死になって守ろうとするやろ。あれが子供に対する愛だ。男がまこの頃ちょっと薄れたけど嫁さんを守ろうとする。嫁さんに対する愛だ。家庭を守る家庭に対する愛だ。
それを本当にあのバカども偏差のバカども
平等に愛せんといかんのだなんてこと言う
じゃん。うちがね前子供引っとる時にバカ
がやってきてね。特にマスコミのバカや。
あんた自分のとこの子供でも殴れるの
かっていう。お前な自分の子供を殴るのは
それは親じゃないじゃっつったら自分の
子供が殴れるわけないやろ。それは
消しからんて。どの子供も平等に扱えんと
いかんでね。お前できるの?どの子供も
平等に扱えることになったら家庭が崩壊
するで。男は朝[笑い]外に出かけて仕事
をしてくる。稼ぎにくいんやね。ところが
夕方になるとなんとなくそワそわしてくる
。子供が見えんようになったからない。
大丈夫だろうかと。子供に対する愛がある
からね。子供を守ろうとして夕方帰って
くるんだ。それがどこの子供でも同じよう
に愛せるんなら遠くまで帰らずに会社の隣
のうちに入っていくぜ。隣のうちに入って
いっても男は安心しやないか。愛するや
そこにおるんやからさ、この程度のことが
分からんのか。
ご質問いいですか?本能から来る愛国心っていうところで家族とか親族までは僕も分かるんですけど国に広がるかどうかっていうのはちょっと別の総点かなと思ってまして
あれはねあれがあの朝日の悪いとこなんや国を愛するのは消しからん子よりこうこうより子で子よりこうは間違いだと
子っていう
公けこうより子が正しいんだと言い続けたやないか朝日だから国を売ったって自分が安
ならええんだということになっちまう。
そうやね。国があるから自分があるんや。
例えばな子よりこうって言うんなら子が
1人1個人が滅びた時にこの滅びるか滅び
へんやろ。こうよりこだからこうよりこ
だったらこうが滅びた時に子が滅びるや
ないか。そうやね。だからこうの方が大事
に決まっとるやん。自分1人の問題やない
んや。全体の問題なんや。
それを全体のことを考えるのは消しからんていうのがあのバカ朝日の言ったことない。あれが偏差だ。
GHQ
に脅かされてお前ら先犯にするぞと言われたらな何でも言うこと聞いちまう。弱いからやね。
愛国士について強い人と弱い人がいると思うんですけど、
これはどうお考えですか?
それはしょうがないよ。うん。どんなことだって強い人と弱い人がおるんやからね。
だからできるだけ強く強くするためには
これ後で授況の時に言うけどね
を養う。本能を確立するんや。これが強い
ということ。本能のトレーニングなんかし
てないやろ。だからみんな本能が弱くなっ
ちまう。本能が弱くなると平気で嘘が
言える。責任を取らない。こういう人間と
してはあまじきことが起こってくるんや。
今みんなそうやね。教育が悪いから何の
責任も肝じんわね。
国に対してから国に対して責任を感ずる俺たちがちゃんとしなくっちゃ困わんといかん。これ愛国心ない。守る国を守る
本能のお話だと仲間とか自分の見える範囲で仲間を大切にするっていう愛国心は分かるんですけど日本っていう国ってちょっと抽象的な概念のような気もするんですけど
群れだ。群れを大事にする今意識できるじゃん。マスコミは毎日東京は今日こういう風でした。
銀座はこんな風でした言っとるんだから日本中を意識できるやろ毎日のように昔はそんなことできんやったやん。だから自分の周りだけなん見える範囲しか意識しなかったからね。
昔の人たちは群れを大切にしてそれでどうやってまとまってたんですかね?
群れのまと群れ。群れのまた群れ。群れを大事にするというあれがあれば大きな群れだって大事にできるということ。
それができなかったら大きな群れは大事に
できないから学校でさえまとまれん。国会
はバラバラ。こんなことをリーダーたちが
やっとる。マフの意見はそれぞれ。これは
見とねなんだということになるわな。なん
でこんな国俺の命をかけてまで守らんと
いかんのや。昔は守らんといかんと思えた
んや。本能がしっかりしとるから。今それ
が思えんのや。あればっかりしてくる。
税金は取り上がる。
なんかちょっとやったらすぐ責任取れ言って刑務処理放り込まれるそんなことばっかり上がやっとるもんでさ。なんでだんだん愛国心が薄れてくるわね。オリンピックや国際的な試合ぐらいしか愛国心の発ができんわな。
昔の人だと今の人だとこうどの辺が違っかみたいなもう
1回伺ってもいいですか?
本能が弱いんよ。今だってね。本能を強くするというトレーニングしてもらった。そうやろ。どうしたらええか知っとる。
本能については無視しってヨーロッパ流の
精神論だからなへから理性が正しいんで
あってほんのは間違っとるんだと散々
叩き込まれたやないか理性的な行動しろと
理性的であれとあいつら分かってなかった
んやであの学者どはただヨーロッパの真似
をもしただけやろ
[音楽]最後にこの動画見てる方で愛国心
を強く持ちたいと思っているんですけど
なかなかこう実感として強くない時も
[音楽]あるみたいな人に対してこうどう
すればいいとかアドバイスありますか?
こんなものはね、本能を強くせんといかんから。本能を強くする方法を講じたらええんだ。そしたら愛国心も自然に本能の
つやから強くなるの。今うちがやっとんのはそれなんやからまたにするかな。その具体的な方法はね。ここが味そなんだ。よう考えてみ。投は最初あのカ朝日は何て言ってた?緒障害って言ってたやろ。
途中から言わんようになった。情緒障害と
言ったらちょっと困る。まずいことができ
てきたからね。で、うちはそれを直す情緒
障害という意味は情緒本能のランクにおけ
る感情。それが障害されている。つまり
本能が狂っているという意味なんや。情緒
障害っていうのは。そうするとそれを
直そうとする。どうしたらええ?
カウンセリングで治るか?カウンセリング
は理性やろ。性は本能には届かないよ。
本能を左右する、使う[音楽]ことはでき
たって。本能そのものを強くしたり弱くし
たりそういうことはできないよ。変えたり
。本能が狂っているのは本能が弱いからや
ないか。弱いとすぐ狂うやろ。筋肉だって
トレーちゃんとしないと走った時、腕立て
て不正をした時すぐにこう痙攣が来たり
崩ってくるやろ。精神だってそうなんや。
弱いとすぐ狂うんだ。だから[音楽]強く
しとかんといかん。だから本能を強く
しようよ。で、これを授況では公然の木を
養うって言うんや。本能には2つあるやろ
。1つは自分に関する本能生きようとする
とかね。呼吸をちゃんとするとか。もう1
つは他の間のもの人全部自分以外はただ
その間の本能こっちの方が難しいんや。
これトレーニングがいるんや。まず自分に
対する本能をしっかり作る。そうすると
ありがたいことに人間性が高くなるんだ。
人間性を社会に対して使った時社会性って
言うんだ。だから高いちゃんとした正しい
社会性を作ろうと思ったらまず人間性を
高めんといかんねん。それとね、最後に
ちょっと1つ言っとくとね、ショート動画
がち流れるやろ。あれに関しては私は
チェックしてないから。で、それに関する
苦情は受け付けません。諸君があれを切っ
て張り合わしただけやからね。それを1つ
コメントはね、こっちまで届かんから。だ
からもしうちに対するコメント文句がある
やろなあ。バカだバカだって言うんだから
。だからそのコメントはとかヨット
スクールを支援する回というメールくれれ
ば時間があれば答えるし直接の方がよく
分かるからね。相手がどこが分からんかが
分かる。だからヨットスクルを支援する会
の方にメールを送れね。精神に関するもの
色々論争があるし、いろんなことを言う人
がおってみんな自分が正しいと言うんだ
から。セミナーに奇数月に東京名古屋大阪
とやってるからもしそれに参加したい人数
に制限があるもんでヨッスクールを支援
する会塚ヨッスクールを支援するのホーム
ページを見てもらえばでそこに申し込んで
もらえば席は取ります。
ただし満席になったらもうちょっと勘弁願いたい。あれはね、消防法によってそこの部屋の人数以上に入れてはいかんのだということをよろしく。
リンクも動画の概要欄にも記載します。